To go over some useful project setups here
The first thing we want to do is go to the project settings
Which can be found on the edit tab on the top of your unreal editor and you can just go down to project settings
So go next to file click edit at the top left hand side of your editor go down to project settings
And you can also find the rendering tab if you scroll down a little bit under our so rendering just just here
And so the things that we're looking at mainly right now are the packaging mode
So we can talk about the actors on a per actor basis
So, how do you want to package the actors and this is the one file per actor setup in the world settings
You can also use external actors on the the level side. So when you click on a per actor basis
Inside your editor, you're just selecting the individual assets and you can package it that way also on the world settings
And if you don't have your world settings tab open in your editor
You can just go to window and then click world settings and that will appear for you
So you can do it on the level basis and you can also do it on the project basis with the extension there
When we're talking about virtual shadows and textures again in the rendering tab
We can go to the virtual textures section here. Have a look through some of these properties
Decide what works for you in terms of optimization
again, there's no real
Way that we can say set XY and Z set into exactly this because everyone's optimization requirements are different
These are just more pointing you in the right direction of the types of things that you could be changing to get
performance out of the project
You've also got the shadow map method here
which you can
Choose which option you want there and then also looking at lumen which is the new Unreal Engine 5 lighting system
Which is a fully dynamic global illumination method
so you can set lumen enabled in your project settings and then we also have some
Correlated properties here in the reflections tab and then also the lumen tab. So be sure to check out those properties